Developers, entrepreneurs,
designers and all the rest,
please come a little closer.
Here's one of the secrets
that we wanted to tell you.
>> The key is to focus on
the long time value of the users.
This is the best way for
sustainable, profitable businesses.
If there's one thing you should take
out from this lesson, this is it.
>> So we're done.
>> Almost.
Let's go just a bit deeper here.
You want to avoid a quick sell,
Netflix, Basecamp, Zendesk,
and many more are giving the user
the opportunity to try before they buy.
Moreover, they let users
use their service on almost
any device from any shape and form.
This is another critical success factor,
be everywhere.
One look at the amount of devices that
Netflix supports will reveal to you
what we mean by saying be everywhere.